c'est à couper le souffle
[Musique]
là où tu vois du sable imagine de l'eau
si tu plonges tu peux même pas toucher
le fond tu plonges dedans ouais ça
s'appelle nager
[Musique]
bien des secrets
mais le plus sombre de tous demeure
peut-être
[Musique]
la fin de la maison hantée ton père ne
croyait pas à la vengeance
et si Paul a trahi était toujours en vie
qu'est-ce que tu as déjà rêvé de ta
première chevauchée
mais c'est pas d'impressionner qui que
ce soit
tu es courageuse on sait tous
va au plus simple va au plus direct
pas de fantaisie d'accord je comprends
rien
pas de
[Musique]
tu ne me perdras jamais par la triste
nous leur avons donné quelque chose à
espérer
en mille morceaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]